every afternoon but doctors from the aid
organization emergency make their rounds
driving over bumpy roads and past tired
laborers we're in the southern Italian
province of apulia just 10 kilometres
from its capital forger the doctors are
a lifeline for the African laborers
hundreds of them live here in the middle
of the fields in makeshift shelters ibas
only fundamentally we provide basic
health care and guarantee rudimentary
rights the people here are entitled to
that depression during Andrea bell rd
nelly and his team of doctors first came
here four years ago since then the
relief organization has become a
permanent fixture the migrant laborers
aren't just here for the harvest they
live here the whole year round al giorno
job they work all day long for a
pittance in order to make ends meet
occasion days in the summer and autumn
they pick tomatoes and now they're
harvesting olives it's no wonder most of
them suffer from chronic muscle and
joint pain ET dolore ertiga larry moss
ferrari molto molto intense
the mission of the Italian organization
is to provide free medical help here in
southern Italy and in many other parts
of the world sometimes the doctors just
provide advice this man originally from
Gambia is plagued by back pain for
months on end he picked tomatoes 25
crates of them a day for a meager six
euros a day unscrupulous farmers imply
the refugees and migrants from Africa as
cheap labor without any form of social
security the tomatoes they pick are
destined for supermarkets across Europe
in Foggia a whole ghetto has sprung up
thousands of people live here without
electricity or running water that angers
the doctors from emergency mission 1 and
n lucky for me tariff walk or we can
only point to their predicament we don't
have the means or power to fundamentally
change anything yet she and it's not
just doctors in Apulia who face this
dilemma andrea bell rd nelly also
coordinates aid teams in Calabria and in
Sicily lukic or so is his contact person
in August onika tanya in Sicily Luke and
his team care for people who were
rescued from the Mediterranean off the
coast of Libya more than 300,000
migrants have arrived in southern Italy
in less than two years in this way Luca
was called out to deal with an emergency
an Egyptian injured his arm trying to
escape from the detention center people
with no chance of asylum are prepared to
take desperate measures she saw no but a
walk I do delivery to the side slit
their wrists or jump into the sea matter
crazy things happen here christison
sudden pogi knology virginity was
sabbatical the aid workers know that not
all of the migrants are political
refugees with the right to asylum in
Europe but almost all of them need
medical assistance of some kind the
greatest cause of concern are
unaccompanied minors and women with
young children so don't equal Josie yes
I've met a lot of courageous women who
have lost children and their partners on
the journey here vicious bessica the
moving thing is that they have
consciously taken the risk of losing
children or being separated for family
members when they set out for Europe in
Siena v Valeo need to know I'm working
here on a daily basis really gets you
down but you also get the feeling you're
doing some good at least I hope that's
the case
spero ds3 will do it at the end of the
visit each patient has given a document
listing their personal data any
medications they're taking or if they
have any chronic illnesses the doctors
encounter many of the migrants from the
Sicilian reception camps again in Apulia
this is how their dream of Europe ends
working as pitifully paid day laborers
andrea bella di Nellie is shocked by the
plight of migrants in Italy man kitakami
vivo even if they ultimately get a
residence permit far too many people
live in inhumane circumstances and that
in a country like Italy which has a
commitment to protecting human rights we
have salad is better the delete command
the International Medical organization
emergency has no shortage of work even
on its doorstep and nobody could have
imagined that when it was founded 20
years ago